good morning everyone and welcome to the
London School of Economics and political
science welcome to those here in the
room as well as those who are listening
online my name is veena Shafiq and i'm
the director of the London School of
Economics and political science in 23
days the UK will leave the European
Union after a difficult period of
political uncertainty and negotiation
but leaving will not be the end of the
UK's relationship with the EU a
relationship built on a shared history
shared values and similar hopes for the
future what will this new relationship
look like to set out her vision of the
crucial next steps I am delighted to
welcome president Ursula van der Leyen
president of the European Commission
back to the LSE today now some of you
may have noticed in the announcement of
today's event that it referred to dr.
van der Leyen
as an LSE alumna first and president of
the European Commission
second you may think we've got the order
wrong but it simply reflects how proud
we are of her achievements as a former
student of the school a place where she
herself has said she found an inner
freedom which which has stayed with her
ever since and which has led her to go
on to being the longest-serving cabinet
minister in Tulsa Merkel's government
and most recently as the first woman to
serve as Germany's defense minister and
now as president of the European
Commission and we are also proud of her
daughter who is a graduate of the school
and her other daughter who will soon be
joining the school so it is a long and
very personal and close relationship but
moving on to her current role as
president of the European Commission
the topic of her speech today old
friends new beginnings building a new
relationship a new future for the EU UK
partnership could not be more welcomed
and more timely at this particular
moment now just a few logistics for
Twitter users the hashtag for today's
event is hashtag LSE Europe and this
event will be recorded and podcast and
available for live streaming there will
be time for questions after the lecture
and I'll take questions from members of
the public and students and also take
some questions from the press as well so
please join me in welcoming dr. Ursula
van der Leyen
president of the European Commission
[Applause]
thank you very much what a pleasure to
be back here at London School of
Economics it is a place indeed that
brings back many many memories to me so
the year I spent one year one year only
at the London School of Economics but it
taught me so much it taught me a lot
inside LSE and taught me a lot outside
LSE as you can guess and anyone who knew
me at that time will tell you that I
probably spent more time in Soho bars
and Camden record stores than in the
Senate House Library so to spare me my
own blushes I'll spare you the details
of that but what I can say is that the
time I spent here opened my eyes I got
to know a warm vibrant colorful
multicultural society the likes of which
I had never experienced before
I saw people from different walks of
life going out together and joy in life
breathing freedom I immersed myself in
the melting pot of cultures traditions
and music indeed and I truly fell in
love with this city and this country
this country strong willed open-minded
big-hearted proud and patriotic kind and
generous and spirit full of traditions
full of contradictions too and it took
me a while to understand for example the
fantastic sense of humor of the British
people
and that it is a subtle meaning hidden
in every sentence but it's only deepened
my fascination and my admiration for the
United Kingdom which remains as strong
today as it was back then and you can
imagine that in the period just before
and after the referendum I thought a lot
about my London time I say this just not
only because of my love for this country
but also because of what the United
Kingdom has brought to Europe and the
European Union in a very understated
British way I think we do not always
talk enough about that and therefore
allow me to look a little bit back
before we look forward before the ashes
of the Second World War even settled it
was Winston Churchill who made the best
case for a united Europe I read out
passages from his 1946 Zurich speech of
famous speech the last time I was here
it is the most eloquent and powerful
case for the European Union you could
ever wish to read and if you haven't
read it I can only recommend to do so
and while the UK initially chose to be
on the outside it eventually took its
place on the inside making us both that
much stronger the relationship may not
always have been smooth or perfect but
what relationship ever is and in my
opinion the good far outweighs the
difficult as president of the European
Commission I want to pay tribute today
to all those British people who
contributed so much to the 45 plus years
of European Union membership I think of
the British pragmatism and leadership
when it came to opening up our union to
members of our family who have been out
in the cold for so long the SEC's
as if European Union enlargements were
historic steps for our continent and
they bear British homer I think of those
who helped to build our institutions
people like commissioner Arthur [ __ ]
field who was known as the father of the
single market or Roy Jenkins he was
president of the European Commission
while I was at LSE who did so much to
pave the way for single currency I think
of the European civil servants of
British nationality who devoted their
lives and their careers to Europe and
have done so much to build our Union
they will always be part of our family I
think of the British servicemen and
servicewomen who have helped to keep the
peace from the Balkans to the Baltics
and I think of the millions of ordinary
Spritle p-pretty people who have taken
to the streets in pro your pian marches
in the last few years of course
[Applause]
this is one of them of course
indeed for them and for many millions
more the results of the referendum was a
bitter pill to swallow but it is people
who make politics and the decision of
the British people in the June in June
2016 was clear as much as we regret it
the European Union has always fully
respected that decision you have seen
this throughout the last three and a
half years our negotiations were hard
and they were long but the European
Union negotiated in good faith trying to
find solutions that defend our own
interests and respect the UK's choice it
is an agreement that we negotiated with
our people and the integrity of the
European Union and mind it is one that
preserves the remarkable peace and
progress on the island of Ireland over
the past 20 years and I will not go into
the ins and outs of the negotiations of
the divorce
Jesus done and dusted as far as I am
concerned before the end of the month I
expect both the British and the European
Parliament's to ratify the agreement and
so in just over three weeks on the 30
31st of January the UK will spend its
last day as a Member State this will be
a tough and emotional day but when the
Sun rises again on February 1st the
European Union and the United Kingdom
will still be the best of friends and
partners the bonds between us will still
be unbreakable
we will still contribute to each other
societies like so many Brits have done
in the European Union and as so many
year many citizens do here every single
day
whereas teachers
whereas nurses as doctors we're working
as CEOs or in NGOs we will still have a
lot to learn from each other the UK is
home to thriving creative and cultural
sectors - cutting at digital innovation
and scientific excellence in some of the
world's best universities with brilliant
minds many of them from all across
Europe we will still share the same
challenges from climate change to
security we will still be allies and
like-minded partners in NATO the United
Nations and other international
organisations we will still share the
same values and the belief that
democracy freedom and the rule of law
must be the foundation of our societies
we will still share the same history and
geography and whatever happens our
continent will still share the same
destiny - so as one door will
unfortunately closed another one will
open and now is the time for us to look
forward together it is the time for the
best and the oldest friends to build a
new future together
and as only true friends can I want to
be very honest about what lies ahead of
us during the withdrawal agreement
negotiation there was always the
uncertainty around where the brexit
would happen or not it was an
uncertainty that made the negotiations
inevitably tense this fresh negotiation
ahead of us will take place against the
backdrop of clarity and mutual interest
in making it work the European Union is
ready to negotiate a truly ambitious and
comprehensive new partnership with the
United Kingdom
we will make as much as we can we will
go as far as we can but the truth is
that our partnership cannot and will not
be the same as before and it cannot and
will not be as close as before because
with every choice comes a consequence
when every decision comes a trade-off
without the free movement of people you
cannot have the free movement of capital
goods and services without a level
playing field an environment labor
taxation and state aid you cannot have
the highest quality access to the
world's largest single market the more
divergent there is the more distant the
partnership will be and without an
extension of the transition period
beyond 2020 you cannot expect to agree
on every single aspect of our new
partnership we will have to prioritize
the European Union's objective and the
negotiations are clear we will work for
solutions that uphold the integrity of
the European Union it's single market
and its customs union there can be no
compromise on that but we are ready to
design a new partnership with zero
tariffs zero quotas zero dumping a
partnership that goes well beyond trade
and it is unprecedented in scope
everything from climate action to data
protection fisheries energy transport
space financial services and to security
and we are ready to work day and night
to get as much
Dannan within the time frame we have
none of this means that it will be easy
but we start this negotiation from a
position of certainty goodwill shared
interests and purpose and we should be
optimistic we need to be optimistic we
need to be optimistic for those young
people leaving school in the next years
who want to study and learn abroad we
need to be optimistic and we need to
look to how British and European
researchers could work together to find
solutions of our most pressing
challenges and to develop the new
technologies the world does really need
and we must ensure that we continue to
work together on upholding peace and
security in Europe and around the world
we must build a new comprehensive
security partnership to fight
cross-border threats ranging from
terrorism to cyber security to
counterintelligence events in recent
years in Salzburg Manchester London and
all across Europe have underlined the
need for us to work together on mutual
security the threat of terrorism is real
and we have to share the necessary
information and intelligence between the
European Union and the United Kingdom to
stop terrorists from crossing borders
and attacking our way of life the nature
of today's threats means that no one can
deal with these challenges on its own
this is even more true for foreign
policies as we see today even though
Britain will be outside the European
decision-making structures there will be
plenty of need for common responses to
address foreign security and development
challenges near and far beyond our
immediate neighbourhood in the east and
south when the Horn of Africa
sahel sub-saharan Africa Oh beaten white
a Middle East or different parts of
Latin America or Asia the truth is that
brexit will not resolve any of the
existing challenges for the European
Union nor for the UK and even being a
part and not bound in the treaties it
will require intensive cooperation on
our foreign and security policies that's
essential that's essential because we
share so much experience and because we
share so many of the same values we have
to uphold these values not only when
it's easy but above all when it's hard
dear friends as we embark on this new
partnership with the United Kingdom the
European Union must also continue to
forge its own path in today's world one
consequence of the brexit vote has been
to strengthen the unity and the faith in
Europe as a project for the common good
the truth is that brexit has highlighted
the value of being together in today's
ever more unsettled world it reaffirmed
our collective belief that we can do
more when we do it together individually
the nations of Europe are becoming
smaller and less influential on the
world scale in 1950 before the Union was
formed the United Kingdom Italy and
Germany were among the 10 most populous
countries in the world 1950 today only
one lifespan later only one of those is
in the top 20
and while Europe's population is set to
declined by the end of the century
Africa's alone will grow by more than 3
billion
at the same time new economies are
emerging and all partners are retreating
back to their own path and we face
change and new challenges ahead of us
climate change for example if there is
one area where the world needs our
leadership it is on protecting our
climate it is existential for Europe and
for the whole world last month we
launched the European Green Deal the
European Green Deal is not only about
emissions it's also about emissions but
not only about emissions
it's about boosting innovation it's
about clean technologies it's about
green financing it's about quality food
it's about modern mobility the European
Green Deal is our new growth strategy
and it will create new businesses and
markets in Europe and across the world
the novelty and the difference is that
we will and can foster a growth model
that is consumed not consuming or
extracting but one that gives back more
to the planet then it takes away from
the planet Great Britain is as dedicated
as the European Union when it comes to
addressing climate change and taking
global leadership a whole continent has
to mobilize and the whole world needs to
be part of this transformation the
European Green Deal won't happen
overnight and it will be demanding and
no country can hope to handle climate
change alone but if this is the right
thing to do and if we do it together we
can lead the change
dear students over the next months and
years we will have to lose them some of
the threats which have been carefully
stitched together between the European
Union and the United Kingdom over five
decades
and as we do so we will have to work
hard to weave together a new way forward
I say this because brexit does not only
mark the end of something on the
contrary it also marks a new phase in an
enduring partnership and friendship it
will be a partnership for your
generation and I count on you all to
make it a success
you can choose collaboration over
isolation you can shape your countenance
dis destiny you can hold your
governments accountable you can refuse
to be satisfied with the status quo and
you can turn things into how they should
be I know the last few years have been
difficult and divisive I hope that by
being constructive and ambitious in the
upcoming negotiation we can all move
forward together there will be tough
talks and each side will do what is best
for them but I can assure you that the
United Kingdom will always have a
trusted friend and partner in the
European Union this is the story of old
friends and new beginning and in this
good sense
long live Europe thank you
[Applause]
okay we have time for questions I'm
going to take the three at a time I'd be
grateful if they were brief I'll take
let me take the gentlemen here I'll take
the woman in the back and I will take
the woman back here in the green so yes
if the stewards could come and if you
could introduce give your name and your
affiliation and then ask your question
hi thank you very much for your speech
my name is arturo bertrand an alumni of
the european institute and Alesi my
question regards the place of citizens
rights in the in the settlement between
the UK and EU that was yesterday a leak
letter by from Michel Barnier
- not directly from you I expect about
the fact that the visual agreement built
at the UK Parliament is passing at the
moment was granting the ability of UK
Minister - what - done some rights about
the future of EU citizens rights in the
UK related to the watchdog that could
help
EU citizens have a proper ability to due
process in the case they were refused
their ability to live in the UK later on
through the set of statues sorry it's a
bit of a nerdy question but what I'm
wondering is how should we do
she ash do you respond to the threat of
a watering then of uses right here in
the ongoing process of the negotiations
thank you thank you
the woman in the back right there with
her arm up and then there was a woman
here in a green top yes
thank you very much my name is Laura
Parker I'm the former European
Commission official proud European and
married to an Italian so mine is the
other half of the question that my
friend just asked which is whether you
would consider associate citizenship for
British individuals I feel torn by the
notion that we leave the EU as a
bureaucratic structure but as someone
who is loves someone from another bit of
the EU I don't quite see how I managed
to leave it so I'd like you to say a
little bit more perhaps about
citizenship for we Brits who want to
continue to be citizens of the European
Union and thank you so much for coming
today hi my name is Georgia I'm a
master's I was really interested in what
we spoke about about sort of the pathway
to future security cooperation and I
thought especially between Britain the
EU with transnational threats and things
like bilateral disputes with the US and
China things like that what does this
partnership look like in practice in the
future could you repeat the the second
part I didn't really sweat it and what
does the future relationship between
Britain and the EU look like combating
conf disputes in international affairs
and things like the us-china trade war
yep yes of course the question of
citizens rights is a pressing one so the
good news is that whoever first of all
what what the numbers are concerned we
have around 3.5 European Union citizens
living in the United Kingdom and vice
versa around 1.2 1.3 million British
citizens living in the European Union
and all those I'm just addressing those
who live in the opposite region the good
news is where you work and live you can
stay under the same conditions till the
end of your life so you have an absolute
clear status when for example at the
European you live here in the United
Kingdom
rights same possibilities as you have at
the moment being until the end of the
life your life and vice versa in Europe
it is so that you have these rights in
the members state you live in
so if at the moment being you're
situated in Belgium or in Croatia or in
Portugal you have the right to stay and
work forever
under the same conditions in Belgium
Croatia or Portugal wherever you are
the bitter truth man is as I've said the
UK will be third country after brexit
and then we will have to negotiate and
this applies to everything I have been
talking about so we are very open to do
the most because I'm I'm a true believer
that as much exchange as possible we
should allow to our citizens but as I've
said before if for example free movement
of people is excluded well there is a
trade-off to that and therefore it's a
matter of negotiation where we end up at
the very end you know that the European
Union is very open to that question that
we are strong believers that we benefit
both sides very much from the free
movement which goes also for the free
movement of not only people but good
services and capital but those four
principles go together and therefore the
next weeks and month will show at what
point we will end the same goes for for
example Erasmus the same goes for
reached research projects whatever we
decided at 28 with such projects for
example we started we will finish at 28
so the status quo states but the future
is matter to negotiations and therefore
I insist so much on keeping in mind
we have so many common interests that we
should build a strong future mainly if
we look around at the rest of the world
and then we realize how much we share
therefore they should be very very
careful with in these negotiations
really to achieve the most possible for
the citizens and for a good partnership
in the future the question on security
it is internal security and external
security although those are very much
interval but well officially we kind of
separated internally of course we have
to talk about things like Europol or
things like extradition what external
security is concerned there - the UK
will be a third country it can choose if
invited to take part for example in
missions or operations we will have to
negotiate about the other topics for
example being part or taking part in
projects in the European defence agency
eda there are clear rules for third
countries so the UK will be subject of
these rules for third countries or what
the European defence Union is concerned
and the European Defense Fund is
concerned the European Union itself is
at the moment in the process of defining
what the conditions are for third
countries to join specific projects and
the UK will be then a third country that
will fall under these rules of the
European Union we have if we look at the
world and enormous interest on both
sides to work as closely together as we
can you know I have been for five years
defence minister in Germany I have seen
our servicemen and our service women
fighting and working in missions
shoulder by shoulder
I've seen how they defend our values in
this very complicated world and
therefore I really recommend to
ourselves to be clear minded and
farsighted what threats are concerned
and common interests are concerned to
build a security partnership that is
unprecedented and that really meets the
purpose we're all aiming at what China
is concerned there first of all I think
it's important that where do we stand
together for me is always very clear and
petraea over your you were mentioning
the potential won between the United
States and China we will never ever
forget where we come from and on what
side of the table if I may put it that
way we're sitting so I'm a strong
believer in the transatlantic
partnership and friendship although we
do have issues with the white house
but you know we're looking back on seven
decades seventy years and more of a
friendship that is built of millions of
contacts in the cultural sector in
science in the business sector personal
friendship and this is the foundation we
do have and from that foundation on we
can tackle these issues too so to be
very clear where we are I think it is
very important that conflicts and trade
we always keep in mind who will benefit
at the very end and therefore I would be
very welcoming if they are sensible and
smart agreements we can find with China
with China we have sinus China's various
searches China's very far reaching by
now I think we have to be very clear on
topics where we disagree very clear on
that we have to be very clear in the
cyber domain where we have a lot of
words but on the other hand there are
other topics where we have common ground
for example the topic of climate change
China's starts now to introduce the
emission trading system and is coming to
the European Union and Commission and
asking for our experience we had with
introducing the emission trading system
which is good because in an ideal world
over time fighting climate change we
need a worldwide budget of co2 with the
emission trading system on it and co2
has to have a price so if we get China
long to go into that topic together with
that is good for us it's good for China
it's good for the planet but as I said
you have to be very frank on other
issues human rights cyber security where
we have huge differences
okay thank you let me turn to some
colleagues from the press maybe John
pano from BBC and then maybe James and
then Sam the coats thank you very much
John Pienaar BBC News
might it be possible to agree the
outline of a deal in the time available
may be covering goods and then continue
negotiating or without a transition must
it be all or nothing by the end of the
year and then James James mates ITV News
Madam President on a similar note when
Boris Johnson says to you this afternoon
I want a comprehensive and ambitious
free-trade agreement and I want it by
the end of the year will you say to him
yes let's go for it or no you can't have
both maybe one wall here in the front
some coats from sky geese in your speech
you suggested that we could be on track
for a zero tariff zero quota deal
what kind of obligation is one
derogations might Britain have to adhere
to to get that or we simply offering
that here today the transition time
it is very very tight and I briefly
touched on the topics we have to
negotiate and this was not even the
whole list of it so it is basically
impossible to negotiate all of what I've
been mentioning and the other dose is
that there are two therefore we will
have to prioritize as long as we face
that deadline of end of 2020 and I can
only recommend that with priorities in a
way that we first of all tackle those
topics where at the end of the year when
we're running out of time we will not
have an international agreement or
something to fall back on but only a
hard exit which would not be for the
good for the UK nor would it be good for
the European Union and therefore
priority the priorities will have to be
sorted out I'm deeply convinced that as
I said for all the fields this is huge
what we have to negotiate the I mean net
9 to 10 months at most
because at the very end it has to be
ratified to will be enough but therefore
it's not an all-or-nothing thing but
it's a question of priority priorities
we have to set and we have to work as
hard as possible I would prefer that we
look at the whole scenery during the
summer or before the summer starts would
be better because we might together want
to take a reconsideration of the time
frame before the 1st of July but let us
start first of all at the 1st of
February with soaring the field and
going into the negotiations as I said
we're determined to work as hard as we
can as much as we can
but there are of course limits zero
quota zero tariffs zero damping means
level playing field clear level playing
field on both sides so whatever is
diverging from a level playing field of
course increases or decreases the
uncomplicated access to the single
market and for details we would have to
go through the different fields but if
you take for example no I will not go
into details because otherwise we go
through the whole negotiation now
[Laughter]
actually more than end of 2020 but the
idea behind it is zero coda zero tariffs
zero damping absolute level playing
field fine
the more you diverge from that the more
of course of the less the the the
uncomplicated access to the single
market is there okay thank you very much
final round of questions let me take oh
so many the gentleman back there one
here and I'd like a woman yes over here
thank you thank you very much my name is
Juan Lombardo I'm currently posted to
the MX the Mexican embassy here in
London and also an LSE alumni so my
question has to do with speak up just a
little bit yeah my question yeah can you
hear me yeah my question has to do with
third party negotiations and
particularly with a capacity of the UK
to negotiate with those third parties
particularly with those with whom the EU
has an agreement already like a free
trade agreement so I'm one my there's a
bit of confusion here but my
understanding is that the UK would only
be capable of negotiating once they
formally leave the EU and those third
countries will be notified by the
Commission that you preside murim
so my question is when well that
notification will come to those third
countries letting us know when the UK is
legally capable of negotiating a free
trade agreement and no longer binding by
the agreements that he has as a member
of the EU one here
who's next uh me thanks knock five Chun
four News thank you very much for coming
wonderful speech just to get back to the
question of convergence you've laid out
your store very clearly here we also
know from members of the boys Johnson
government that there are those who are
looking for a kind of Singapore on the
Thames model to what extent do you
perceive that to be a threat to the
interests of the European Union and what
are you prepared to do about it
I think it's okay
my name is Inga I am an LSE alumni as
well and researcher with Elysee ideas in
the dahrendorf forum you emphasize the
joint challenge facing the EU in the UK
regarding security and talked about the
EU in the UK being like-minded allies in
NATO you also mentioned the friction in
the White House given macrons recent
comments the situation in Turkey and the
US military actions do you think NATO is
a viable alliance for the future and
will you know contribute to the
relationship between the EU or the UK or
do you think it will create even more
challenges to write it down I must admit
I didn't really get the question all
above but so when when will the UK have
the green light to do third party
negotiations okay I look at Michelle
bond you when will it be
the show
I say you know just come join me
[Applause]
you know as the president said leaving
the using evocative is huge and very
very many consequences and I just want
to repeat that leaving the you the
single bucket and the custom Ian means
for the UK to leave in the same time
mechanically automatically 600
international agreements among them all
the trade agreements that means that UK
has to rebuild each and every trade
agreement with all the other third
country the world attributes and a very
very important task and what we have
planned in the negotiation in which
women and for the transition that the UK
will be allowed to begin and we know
that they have already begin for last
year many negotiation with many cert
countries none of this Agreement can be
limited before the UK lived and so as a
member states the cannot implement the
the disagreement that means that they
are allowed to negotiate and we give
them this time to negotiate they cannot
be implemented before they leave all
right we go back to Singapore question I
[Music]
would not recommend that we kind of
label the end of the negotiations it
will be the EU UK brand on it and as
I've said I think we have to be very
clear that it's a matter of trade often
choices and nothing will be as it was
before all will change we have to accept
that fact so there is a difference being
a member state and not being a member
state what access
and ease is concerned and therefore the
fields will be matter of negotiation I
take a very important field that are the
financial services there - all will
change because right now we are all able
within the 28 if you have a bank that
from home you can operate in a different
Member State easily this will change
this is over and the question is you can
get for some sectors some equivalences
which is kind kind of the the being
allowed to operate that way but this is
a decision then unilateral from the
European Union and therefore a whole of
topics a lot of topics we have to go
through and figure out how we end up at
the very end of course both sides have
their strengths and their weaknesses
both sides have a field where they are
better and they are not as good off and
therefore it is a matter also of always
looking at the mutual interest we do
have at the very end we want our
economies to to prosper at the very end
we want our citizens to have an easy
life going back and forth at the very
end we want science and research and
wonderful universities like this one to
be open on the continent and here in the
UK so if this is the goal we have to try
to minimize as much as possible
the possible the deviation from the
level playing field and to negotiate as
fast and as intensive as possible to
have a smooth ongoing because again I
say there are other challenges out there
in the world we have to tackle together
and that leads me to the third question
NATO
I'm deeply convinced that collective
defense article 5 in NATO will always be
NATO and this is good
NATO is the strongest military alliance
in the world and this is good too the
European Union will never be a military
alliance it's much broader and way
different and it has completely
different means and influence we have
over the last three and a half years
started to build up the European defense
union which is complementary to NATO
following the idea that as 27 it is
smart to be into a high degree
interoperable to procure together to
develop and research together this is
smart in doing it and to get our act
together if I may put it that way
it's also in NATO's interest because 22
of the European member states are also
member in NATO so it's in NATO's
interest but I see many fields besides
the purely question of collective
defence which is a very important one
we're also the European Union is being
called upon and therefore it has to get
structures and procedures as I was
saying in the European defence Union but
also the wide field of Economic
Development neighborhood diplomacy all
the topics that are needed to not only
win or settle a conflict but to win
peace than afterwards and give people a
perspective for their future and at the
moment being I always think that we
should never ever underestimate the
importance of the ability to have a
dialogue and to have trusted relations I
know that during times
where there are tensions and conflicts
that is dominant but at a certain point
in every conflict you have to go back to
talks and then it's helpful to have
established channels to have trusted
relations where you can start again to
establish some kind of link to get out
of a dramatic crisis and to work on
increased peace and reconciliation
within the region and beyond the region
and therefore I'm a strong believer that
NATO is important but I'm very much
convinced that may to also meet the
European Union thank you so much
[Applause]
I wanted to thank you for many things
but really the most important thing is
you've reminded us that the connections
between the UK and the European Union
are grounded in profound and deep
history and common interests and values
and you've reminded us that there's a
very personal dimension to those
connections and many people in this room
I think share those very personal
connections in our own relationships in
their own lives the negotiations will be
about policy policy can diverge and
policy after January 31st will probably
diverge but those personal and there's
very profound common values and interest
will persevere after January 31st and
you've reminded us to keep sight of
those much more important long-term
issues as we enter a very complicated
set of negotiations thank you for coming
and thank you for reminding us of those
big important
[Applause]
please remain in your seats until we're
able to get out of the room thank you
all very much for coming
[Music]